look who it is what are the odds you and
I'd end up at the same summer camp relax
this it's not on you it's on our little
spider friend I've got some boys on the
outside who does love to meet him you
know take a picture slice his throat but
his head in a dryer and I heard a rumor
you know who he is
if I knew who it was
he'd already be dead
your family's here
which captain of industry or
high-ranking political you posing as
this time chameleon this time I have
someone a little different in mind
hey everybody it's Charlie you may have
heard the news they just cast a new
member of the sinister six in spider-man
far from home now there are actually
five members that are rumoured to be in
a three that we know are confirmed so
it's almost like they're building
towards a sinister six team-up
eventually so we got to break this down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Comic
Con videos this week it's gonna be crazy
there's a new round of that infinity war
blu-ray giveaway - all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video the news this
morning is a deadline announced that
they had just cast Dimitri smart Nick
off is the first version of the
chameleon literally debuted in amazing
spider-man number one so in addition to
chameleon now we have confirmed vulture
Scorpion Mysterio and that only makes
four there was also reported concept art
showing a battle with spider-man in
Venice fighting hydro-man who is another
lesser member of the sinister six so
already that's five members wouldn't it
be funny if they only had five members
in spider-man far from home leaving that
sixth member for the official sinister
six team up for the third spider-man
film you all probably know about Kevin
Feige 'he's pitch for the movie sort of
the one-liner synopsis is that the
spider-man is on vacation with his
friends in Europe we know it picks up
minutes after Avengers 4 but the first
big place that they go to is London the
only other places that we know that he's
going are Venice and Prague based on the
concept art with a big battle at each
place so you can see they're kind of
building towards a big battle with a
different person in each big location so
if those are gonna be the only places he
might just be travelling around Western
Europe when they said that be sort of a
globe-hopping adventure I envisioned him
going more places but i can assume if
they're gonna go with the traditional
three-act structure you can only go so
many places and fight so many villains
before the film gets too stuffed and if
they're already doing four to five
members of the sinister six it sounds
like they have everything they need to
build up to a genuine spider-man verse
the sinister six in whatever that third
spider-man film ends up being the really
interesting thing to remember too is
this is the last movie on the contract
with Marvel that Sony's signed so if
things went bad
this would have been their last
spider-man film to make which is why
they probably decided to go so fast into
sinister 6 in this way now obviously
some of the members of the sinister six
are different from the classic roster
Kevin Feige said they were trying to do
different characters that they'd never
done before so that's probably why you
haven't heard about Norman Osborn or
Doctor Octopus because they've done
those characters so many times before
the really cool thing that they're
implying is is they're doing a version
of the original Mysterio story albeit
with sinister six members and it also
kind of resembles the plot of amazing
spider-man annual number one where he
fought the sinister six the first time
he just ran the gauntlet like he would
go around to different parts in New York
City fighting a different villain having
a different kind of battle if you've
never watched any of the animated
spider-man series there was one called
spectacular spider-man a couple years
ago that did a version of what it seems
like spider-man far from home is doing a
team up between the chameleon in the
Quentin Beck Mysterio so Quentin Beck
provided all the tech the chameleon
needed to masquerade as spider-man which
was a spin on one of the first big
Mysterio battles against spider-man
separate comic book story but the
cartoon sort of mashed those things
together and it kind of seems like
that's what the movie is going to be
doing - so no paycheck no paycheck but
the story in the book it sparked an
epiphany Mason I need all your
mechanical ability
and BEC your special-effects expertise
yes so what else is new which captain of
industry are high-ranking political you
posing as this time chameleon this time
I have someone a little different in
mind
fun animation fact the same person that
created that spider-man cartoon is the
same person that created Young Justice
it's Greg Weissman there's gonna be a
big Young Justice season 3 panel at
comic-con this week the really important
thing to remember too is then how does
this affect everything else that's going
on in the Marvel Universe because
remember how they were gonna use Kraven
in the Black Panther movie Ryan Coogler
was like I really wanted that character
but they told me to sit on it and we
ended up using kill monger instead I
think the movie was better for it he can
come back any time you want especially
if they want to do a spider-man black
panther crossover but the cool thing
about them doing the original version of
chameleons in far from home is that he's
actually the brother of Kraven in the
comics he has this really tortured
backstory eventually he swore revenge on
spider-man after Kraven killed himself
after battling spider-man just in
disgrace because he's all about being
the hunter Kraven the master hunter if
he fails at that he feels like a
disgrace so eventually he wound up
killing himself his half-brother a
chameleon swore revenge on spider-man
so obviously the plot of the movie is
gonna be a little bit different but just
the idea that you can now connect Kraven
which they were gonna use in the Black
Panther movie to what's going on during
the course of spider-man far from home
like Kevin Feige says they're laying
seeds that they can grow into stories
later on if they want to the main thing
those are still trying to lock down Jake
Gyllenhaal is the Mysterio character in
the comics Mysterio's crimes had been
thwarted by a spider-man so to get
revenge he tried to incriminate him by
dressing up like spider-man committing
crimes to make it seem like spider-man
was a criminal then trying to prop up
himself in the community to make people
think that he was a hero by taking
spider-man down in a public battle so we
could be seeing a version of that where
you have Mysterio the big villain of the
movie pulling the strings with all these
different villains that spider-man is
battling that are on their way to
becoming the sinister six so after the
events of this post-credit scene you
have to assume that a little while has
gone by they fix the universe during
Avengers 4 somehow these criminals get
out vulture is going to be in
movies so I'm assuming that scorpion
also breaks out of prison too if their
sentences aren't done or if whatever
they do at the end of Avengers 4 doesn't
undo some of the end of some of these
other movies which I don't think that it
will I think that they'll just break out
of prison but you can understand why
vulture in disgrace might be hiding out
in Europe and get tied up in all the
sinister six mess even though he kind of
owes spider-man one but to be fair he
did kind of pay back that debt by not
turning his name over to scorpion here
so all this evidence just points towards
Kevin Feige doing a version of some of
the old-school spider-man comics that
built up towards a first sinister six
battle doing like a slightly different
version of that assuming that this was
going to be the last movie I'm sure that
they had plans to make it a real
sinister six team-up but now that it
seems like they're gonna renew their
sharing arrangement and there will be a
third spider-man film that they'll do
together they'll probably push the
official team up to that next movie like
spider-man battles vulture scorpion
Mysterio chameleon maybe hydro man if he
really is in the movie and then they
slowly come together like this
spider-man is the bane of our existence
we need to band together to take him
down in that becomes the third
spider-man film but remember there's
still a missing character if Quentin
Beck isn't going to be the leader of
this version of the sinister six even
though he's the big villain of this
movie doesn't mean that there's always
another bigger villain right around the
corner I would be ok if that sixth
member ended up being Kraven in the next
film like they saved him for the genuine
sinister six team-up but let me know in
the comments what do you think about
them doing so much sinister 6 in
spider-man far from home but in
spider-man related news do not forget
the venom panel is on Friday I'll do
another trailer video when they drop
that they'll also probably be dropping
new into the spider verse with other
versions of spider-man like we knew
about Nicolas Cage playing spider-man
noir so leave all your requests in the
comments below
congratulations the latest giveaway
winner emmanuel romano please email me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details click here for
brand new Avengers 4 and click here for
my Aquaman trailer preview thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]